I beg in my Crocs
[Music]
I have left Dunder Mifflin after many
record-breaking years and I am
officially on the job market and it's
very exciting for your convenience I've
broken it down into three parts
professional resume
athletic and special skills resume and
Dwight Schrute trivia I am ready to face
any challenges that might be foolish
enough to face me how would I describe
myself three words hard working alpha
male
jackhammer
merciless
insatiable there's nothing on my Horizon
except everything everything is on my
Horizon
sorry I hope you're not busy doing
something
you're hungry I'm just having lunch oh
yeah that sounds good
[Music]
very loud
wow oh yummy you have got the life my
friend yeah just stay here and never go
back
things not going so well there oh man
how much time do you have
a doctor's appointment next Thursday
yeah
what's your day going to do anything
cool
uh no sweetie I just sort of hung out
because I saw I had shoes on so I didn't
know if you did anything no just hanging
out on you remember Michael oh hi sorry
I was just in the neighborhood and
thought I'd come by and say
College this is great so
you guys up to
um
actually I you know I think maybe we'll
go outside
saber is changing everything
site blockers they don't let us use cups
so I started thinking who could handle
this Who would know what to do
David Wallace would know what to do
what should I do David Wallace I don't
know bro what can you do
exactly what are you thinking
but it's a tough one it is a tough one I
don't have any ideas for you yeah
but one would be good
hey oh okay wait okay I want to tell you
about a business idea I have okay okay
you know how kids leave their toys
everywhere okay
this is a vacuum it's like a Shop-Vac
type of thing
teaches kids how to pick up their own
toys
right baseball gloves uh Hacky Sacks
drumsticks nah
picks it up so the kid's making the
noise
no no no no no that's the that's the
vacuum though okay
okay
no no it's okay another guy from Denver
Mifflin Arnie from research he's gonna
drop the Prototype
and uh
it's like a shop back
say that yep
this is why I do it
that's what I have to come home to
she probably won't
be up for a few hours this is
is my office yep never been used not
super exciting no and this is my
workspace this is it check that out you
smell it uh-huh as you can smell there's
a lot of different odors going on in
here so you have an office and a
workspace I do you know I just I cannot
create in the same space that I conduct
business I'm sure that you're the same
with your Doodles smell
it's fire uh-huh bonfire Bond men love
this one James Bond
Fireball on fire
I get frustrated or irritated or
angry I come up here and I just smell
all my candles I just poof goes away
just like that just like that so what do
you say we get started after breakfast
I'm full
so how you feeling about the new company
wow
you excited about the new company yeah
yeah after breakfast
we did that so what's next
Michael just stop for a second
fine
oh I'm sorry
sorry
I can't do this
this is pathetic isn't it
I am such an idiot
I gave up the only job I ever loved to
do this
I have egg in my Crocs
a week today
I felt much stronger yesterday
Mike Benjamin Button in Reverse you know
Michael when I feel overwhelmed I'm not
overwhelmed Pam I know no I'm saying
that when I feel overwhelmed something I
like to do is make a list
make a list of things to do
and then start with the easy stuff
whatever calms you down okay first
workout and Hey look
you did that check
eat an enormous breakfast
check don't patronize me Pam
I think you should get dressed I'm not
getting dressed I'm not getting dressed
I have too many things to do before I
get dressed so it just goes on under
here like this that's right
oh gosh yeah you never get used to that
hey just wanted to check in see how
you're doing I am so great he's great
we're all great 12 dogs
this is my life now I'm a dog nurse look
at that one though he's smiling yeah he
should be it's his first day without a
muzzle
this is the greatest thing that has ever
happened to me absolutely it's yes I'm
sorry are you guys nuts
he's not doing great he was fired this
is terrible this is literally the worst
thing that has ever happened to you not
the best
you're right
he's right I am a mess this whole night
I've been trying to convince you guys
that I'm fine I guess I thought that if
I could convince you that I'm fine maybe
maybe you would think it too
I'm sorry uh I uh it's just I I don't
get to be in a lot of human
conversations so okay well Andy listen
it's okay if you don't feel totally
settled this is all very fresh yeah I
mean admitting that you need help is the
first step yeah yes and also focusing on
the positive like I got a lot of good
things going on yeah
like that rock opera you could always do
that right yeah I do I have that
yeah you're gonna be all right
no
no he's not
yes I am thank you Kim you're welcome
sometimes I feel like everyone I work
with is an idiot
and by sometimes I mean all times
all the time
every of the time
after Pam dumped me I um
I kind of stopped taking care of myself
for a while there and uh
I hit bottom when uh
drunk driving arrest
well he's always been a lifelong Michael
what's going on I'm hey Ryan Excuse me
yes this wasn't on the list yes it is no
yes it's not it is when did you add this
to the list Pam everyone deserves a
second second chance
Ryan just out of curiosity how much do
you get paid here sixty thousand dollars
a year you get paid by the year at the
bowling alley what do you make secretary
back to work shoe I told you guys
I'm really busy here would you like to
come to work for the Michael Scott Paper
Company
what size shoes are you guys I have nine
what are those men's ten no
please join what is he doing he's still
like him okay okay he's already paying
for himself sorry
where is it right here hey come on guys
these are prime selling Oz you know
nothing
maybe on me
I'm ziplining my third day in Costa Rica
it's the harness wasn't strapped in
exactly right I wrote my net
and
it's kind of a hospital five weeks now
I haven't seen the beach
it's nice to have visitors
all right